so when the history of cable news is
written assuming anyone bothers to write
it but if it ever is written Glenn Beck
will have his own chapter as possibly
the greatest synthesizer of Big Ideas
ever to appear on camera and a lot of
people made fun of Glenn Beck over the
years for that but if you go back and
watch the tape you will find out that
maybe more than any other person on
television Glenn Beck got it right
again and again and again
so we thought tonight is the perfect
opportunity to hear from him he's the
co-founder of Blaze media he's just
written a book called The Great reset
and he joins us now for an overview of
what we're watching Glenn Beck thank you
so much for coming on tonight
well it's true
so let me I I've got a couple of things
here for you um let me just go through
I'm going to bring a I think a different
perspective to this we have the banking
crisis they say it's fine it's just
beginning we um yesterday we had the
Saudis and uh Brazil and
um uh China enter a deal to where the
Petro dollar is over Brazil and China
are going to change trade in their own
currency that's the beginning of the end
of our currency that means a dollar
collapse that means we become Venezuela
we will have war with China we will have
war with Russia and Iran uh we have the
restrict Bill we have social media and
our NSA and everybody else in bed with
each other silencing people we of course
have the raccoon dogs which we all know
is bullcrap and now this week we have a
new uh gun grab that they're trying to
do
um Biden and his family taking money
from the Chinese ease what do you think
this Donald Trump thing is really all
about the American the America that we
knew the fundamental transformation that
started in 2008 is finished we are no
longer viewed as a superpower we are now
a an elderly what we're Joe Biden just
walking in to the Twilight what this is
all about I believe is trying to inflame
this country is in they've wanted
violence from the right from the
beginning they can't wait it they need
it because if we strike out look at
January 6 the day they're letting the
shaman out of prison because it was all
trumped up thank you Tucker Carlson for
revealing this the day they're letting
him out
they do this to Donald Trump they want
you to strike out why because then they
can close the cage I'm going to make
another prediction for you uh Tucker you
said I got it right well everything I've
been talking about since 08 this is the
time I'm going to make a prediction by
we are going to be at War we are going
to have a new dollar a currency that it
probably is coming from the central bank
will have a currency collapse uh and we
will live in a virtual police state I
know that might sound crazy to a lot of
people it's not far off the The Bill of
Rights is gone nobody is paying
attention where are the Republicans
where are the decent Democrats that can
see this is this is insanity Donald
Trump the reason why this is going to
help Donald Trump and that's why I don't
think they're doing it so he can't run
they're doing it because they want
people to strike out please turn to God
repent pray for our country Pray for
Peace put on the full armor of God but
here's what's really what they miss
Donald Trump is not even a person
anymore he is a symbol he is a symbol of
the average everyday guy that keeps
getting screwed every single time
watches other people
screw up big Banks screw up their
companies and get away with it he's they
see people all the time doing stuff that
they know if they did they'd be in
prison for 20 years but because they're
not part of the elite they get away with
it Donald Trump has taken Arrow after
arrow and that's why
this is the way the average American
feels tonight I hope that there's a few
Republic Or democrats out there but this
guy has been taking the bullets for the
average person now for years and people
on the right feel like he's the only guy
that really gets what the people are
feeling and it's uh it's not gonna it's
not gonna end well for the Democrats in
the next election it's just not I don't
know if Donald Trump is the winner or
not but I will tell you this
you're not going to stop a hundred
million people this country is in
shambles
and there's going to be a hundred
million people that will walk on broken
glass and Through Fire to vote for
someone other than this corrupt Banana
Republic Administration
it's I think exactly right Glenn Beck
wow
I'm going to be processing that for a
couple days I really appreciate your
coming on tonight thank you
thank you Tucker thank you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight